um
about another 30 seconds
a spindle
all right and so let's get started and
I'm going to shift the chat to chatting
with just us
some panelists so you can
show
make your comments to us but uh also
when you're
asking questions put them in the Q a and
I'll remind you of that in a second so
this session today is about the
professional certificate course in Ai
and machine learning with IIT contour
and how it can help you get a foothold
in the AI and machine learning industry
ground rules for the session put your
questions in the Q a box as I just
mentioned we are recording the session
and um we will send you a follow-up
email that has a linked recording
and
we will also
tell you about the bonus offer that we
mentioned invited you
um
stay tuned with us to the end of the
webinar to hear about that and if you do
want to request a proof of attendance
for attending this session today
please
um put your name as you want it to
appear on the certificate into the post
webinar survey it'll pop up after you
leave the webinar so
um
moving forward
let's start with a poll about you and
the audience
curious to know how many years of
experience you have are you currently
studying for your degree or are you
in the Working World
I'm going to leave this open for about
20 seconds or so
straightforward question
so please get your answers in and hit
the submit button you will close the
poll in five
four three two one
um
see the result is that about half of our
audience are people who are currently
studying
uh the rest of you are in the Working
World tending to be more experienced so
interesting split of the audience today
that
I'm going to um introduce
simply learn excuse me as I
work my presentation system here
um first off we as you've seen we're
going to be asking questions about you
we'll be talking about
a field of AI and machine learning what
it is what are the things you need to
know about it to be successful in it
and then we'll talk about what this
program offers
how it can help you be successful in it
how it gets you job ready
we'll talk about how to get enrolled if
it's of interest to you and the bonus
offer that we mentioned we'll take your
questions in the Q a so please again put
the questions into the Q a box and zoom
and we will cover those
um later in the session so I'm going to
introduce I'm a team
um actually I'm going to let him
introduce himself but I just wanted to
mention he is one of the Premier uh
Trainers for our program and like all
the other trainers he has extensive
experience both in industry and in
training so I mean if you'd like to
tell a little more about yourself
thanks to Stuart and thrilled to be here
in this webinar session uh just to tell
you a little bit about myself I hold an
MBA degree in i-team and my journey in
the world of analytics has been a really
thrilling one with over 16 years of
corporate experience I had privilege of
diving deep into Realms of training
delivery as well as analytics product
development and if you ask about my true
passion it lies into a statistical
analysis machine learning deep learning
and throughout my career I had pleasure
of training corporate organizations
clocking over 4500 hours of training
sessions on data science Ai and ml tools
and techniques and I'm also honored to
be one of the trainers for the
prestigious institutions like Purdue
University and Caltech in association
with simply learn
and uh in in addition to that I also run
a consulting firm where we create data
driven solution which I have been doing
since last 10 years
and in terms of
uh tools techniques as I mentioned I'm
I'm well versed with AIML and I deal
with python SAS Arc that's what I do
that in a nutshell what I have been
doing
thank you so much auntie
um
simply learn itself is a a provider of
digital boot camps in fact we're the
world's number one online boot camp we
specialize in training professionals
working professionals especially uh in
digital skills for the digital economy
helped over 5 million people upskill in
digital skills over the last 13 years so
we're extremely proud of that we deliver
all of our programs online and so
they're available worldwide we've helped
people in 150 different countries this
particular program we're talking about
today is mainly focused for Learners in
India but it again is available to a
worldwide audience so if you're visiting
from outside India
this is still a program that you can
engage in
and let's talk a little bit everything
about the careers in Ai and machine
learning and you yourself have built a
career in the field
um
so can you comment on this particular
statement
Ai and machine learning extends
mom basically Ai and machine learning
about missing extend human capabilities
that's how we should look at it because
if you look at different applications
which I've been using uh like it could
be Google photos it could be translated
it is actually helping in terms of
extending our own capabilities it is it
is a complementary
technology that we are talking about
it's not something that we need to get
worried and there's there are a number
of tools which have come up which is
helping us in terms of solving some
real-time problem where our
understanding of the domain our
understanding of the problem is equally
important as as machine learnings or AI
applications computation power or
probably their ability to Deep dive in
the data is so that's how I I would look
at it
and
there's a an anecdote from
the history of business that there was a
newspaper article and opinion article
back in the 1920s that predicted that
um every woman in in the industrialized
country would eventually have to be
employed as a secretary or
Administrative Assistant because of the
amount of filing and bookkeeping work
that had to be done and if you projected
out the growth of business and the
number of people required that this
would necessarily create that pattern of
employment of course we Now understand
that
computing power allows us to automate
many of those tasks and so we don't have
a society that's oriented towards
relegating
uh
pool especially women to those kinds of
tasks it means that
we can start thinking about
structuring our society in a more
Equitable way in more productive way and
the same thing is going to be true of AI
and machine learning where
um
these new capabilities
give us
each more scope to explore what we can
do personally and what our employers can
do our organizations can do
um
how do you see that shaping out in the
world coming ahead
in terms of how how kind of what kind of
jobs they're talking about in general
yeah and what in the growth of the
market the
so
so the growth if you see it's uh it's an
exponential growth we are expecting in
this particular field and we require
people with the right tools and
technique knowledge which can come and
help us in terms of building some some
some path breaking applications so going
forward if you'll see how it has how how
like two three decades back when
computers were introduced especially in
India there was a talk about that a lot
of jobs will be lost but what happened
was is that it created a lot of job
market for us and something similar is
happening in this particular domain also
like a lot of things are getting
automated but for doing that particular
job also you need to require uh
professionals who understand these
techniques these these tools and then
they can implement it so if you talk
about in general uh the the growth is is
tremendous the requirement will also be
a pretty uh huge and it's just basically
you need to get into the group and learn
these topics learn these Concepts and
start understanding how you can map
these Concepts to the some some business
problem that you are solving that's how
it will go
and you can see from some of these
statistics here that the
the size of the market in terms of
spending in terms of number of jobs is
really quite staggering yeah it is
so yeah this is a great field a great
choice of career for people who want to
be on that Leading Edge and the the
quote and I'm sorry I didn't find the
source of it but it was a
quoted to me by venture capitalist who
said
AI is not coming for your job people who
understand how to use AI may be coming
for your job
yeah you want to be one of those people
um speaking of which there's different
ways to be part of this industry and
different roles that
take so
um these are all kinds of careers people
can build
uh starting with the foundation of the
AI and ml skills and holding out so
can you comment on you know what
differences there are between these
roles and how people could pursue them
yeah so I'll start with the say data
engineering so if I talk about data
engineering and and machine learning
engineer that we talk about so
data engineering is more about uh
working with the data creating data
pipelines making sure that right quality
of the data is actually pumped into a
machine learning algorithm and it
requires a lot of understanding of how
how data is flowing in the system then
there are data Engineers are responsible
for Designing building and maintaining
the data infrastructures and the
pipeline the plan that we talk about
they also focus on data preparation and
then uh tools and Technologies which are
related to these tasks that's what we
talk about machine learning Engineers if
you talk about in general they focus on
developing and deploying machine
learning models in the system so data
Engineers will help them in terms of
making sure that that data is received
in the right order and then on top of it
they can start building their machine
learning models now also in in terms of
development lot of experimentation
happens in in terms of finding out the
right algorithm write model evaluation
technique hyper parameter tuning and
then they need to understand tools and
Technologies which which is required for
developing those models so in uh if you
talk about relationship between between
data Engineers machine learning learning
ingenious generally they have distinct
roles but they often collaborate with
each other in terms of forming a team
for the data science that's how it goes
then you have ai architect AI developer
when we talk about so this moves
entirely into artificial intelligence so
architect as the names as as the domain
is you need to start understanding how
to build a proper infrastructure for a
particular project and how a particular
model will be developed on a very broad
level and then how data will move how
the output will come how it will work
out in next year or how we'll scale it
going forward what kind of challenges
will come going forward if you are
scaling at a at a different level
altogether that's what Architects would
be doing and then you have a little more
comprehensive job role that we talk
about of a data scientist so data
scientists are basically people who
understand machine learning algorithms
they understand statistical model they
have this skill set of building
end-to-end machine learning or
statistical models they can deploy it
and they can easily connect with the
business requirements so this is how in
general it goes
hi I should unmute myself when I say
that thank you very much for that I
appreciate that the kind of review of of
the paths of the different roles
um so one should feel that there's a lot
of potential for developing a career
um in whatever Direction one wants to go
right
that's correct so what happens initially
you can start with the with the one of
the skill set and you can move laterally
or vertically also that's how it goes
um the foundation is the sets of skills
you kind of see here
this may not be the ultimate
comprehensive list but it's a good
representation of the basics that people
need to know and it builds up from from
the foundational skills to the
techniques to looking into more advanced
topics uh like the ones that that
Fascinate You right so can you take us
through how we how some a learner would
process or progress through these
because also any kind of job role that
you are looking in this particular
domain you have to have some
foundational skills skills done so
statistics and maths is something which
is very important when you want to
understand a particular algorithm how it
works and how the output could be
evaluated so that's where statistics and
maths is very important statistics also
helps you in terms of doing some basic
data cleaning or data transformation
that we talk about and in order to work
with these concepts of beat statistics
on maths or later on little more
sophisticated machine learning algorithm
python comes very handy it has built-in
libraries which can perform a variety of
tasks in no time and this has been a
go-to tool for any kind of machine
learning uh algorithm implementation
that we talk about so that's something
you should know how how to code in
Python and how to create different
pipelines so that's your foundational
skills that's something which you have
to start with
and as you proceed then you'll have
different learning methods on a broad
level you can say you will have machine
learning and you'll have deep learning
which will come under Advanced topics
but within machine learning you will
have different algorithms you will have
supervised learning you'll have
unsupervised learning you might work
with some reinforcement learning
problems semi-supervised so these are
the broad structure structure of
different algorithms that you can apply
on the data and under each of these uh
supervised unsupervised learning that we
are talking you'll have a bunch of
algorithms which you should understand
how do they work and to make sure that
it works perfectly fine with the data
you should know the maths behind it so
you should learn the mathematical
aspects of the model how how do you
implement the data and then also what
kind of challenges you're gonna face so
supervised learning unsupervised this is
what you'll be covering in the next
stage and the last stage that we have
mentioned over here is Advanced topic
which will talk about deep learning in
particular and also the advancement
which is happening within deep learning
framework so it starts you you should
start with the understanding of the
neural network how does it work and how
do we Implement with a framework called
Keras or tensorflow which is a deep
learning framework in Python and then
you you can move towards a newer
advancement such as generative AI which
is top of the Town these days so
generative AI will help you in terms of
generating new data points or new images
in general that speed that's what we do
and then it also has some some other
domain altogether we talk about computer
vision and NLP so this is how you should
move
thank you and and that's kind of the
basic comprehensive set of skills that
you want to have to be capable so let me
ask a question
for our audience because
you're all here of course because you're
interested in qualifying as uh
professional practitioner of a machine
learning
and
we're curious why haven't you picked the
program up to now to qualify to be
certified in AIML
what is it that you've been looking for
that you haven't found in this program
well I'll leave that open for just
another
five seconds you can of course answer
more than one answer so please put in
your answers hit that submit button and
uh to
in the pool now
and so it's a fairly even distribution
um
most people the most popular answer is
you can't find a program that's
comprehensive and covers all the the
kinds of skills that I mean he just
spoke of
um then close behind not feeling that
you would have practical experience
examples to show
uh to demonstrate your new set of skills
to
potential employers or to your current
boss
finding time within your work schedule
and finding it difficult to learn uh in
a non-interactive way so
those are all
valid concerns and those are things that
we had in mind when
worked with IIT Comfort to design this
program
forward
the program is a professional
certificate course in Ai and machine
learning it is an 11 month program
does require you to dedicate about 10
hours a week
um so it's something that you can fit
into a working professional schedule but
you do need to be able to make that
commitment especially committing to the
live class times because the program
includes online live classes where you
interact with an instructor like I'm a
team where you
they'll take you through the integrated
labs and projects you'll use the
different AI tools programming tools
live on your virtual machine that's part
of your learning environment and
then in between classes you'll have
other exercises and projects to work on
you'll have other
materials to review to prepare for the
following these class so it's a
something that you not only need to show
up to the classes but you need to
dedicate a little time during the week
to continue your education and move
forward
it features a comprehensive and Industry
aligned learning path IIT confer works
with a number of companies and they have
said
this is what we need we're hiring people
into this field
so the learning path is designed to meet
those industry needs and prepare you for
work in that environment so when we talk
about
the Hands-On Labs I mean this is really
a program that's designed to learn by
doing isn't it
it is actually and and the field is such
that you have to learn and then you have
to implement on a real world problem
when we talk about the real world
problems it's
a series of exercises in each of the
modules and we'll get into the module
shortly
uh where each has a
set of projects you can choose from
within that module focusing on the topic
of that module but then we talk about a
final project a Capstone project that
kind of ties that all together so we're
really helping people to build out
examples of how they would
do this kind of work in the real world
right that's correct and the idea is
this that you understand the concepts
and through uh uh
multiple case studies projects that we
have uh curated for you you will
understand that how a concept could be
used in different domain different
industry and it also gives you a lot of
understanding of different stages you go
through when you are working on a
particular project which is there so it
actually helps you a lot in terms of
understanding how to implement an
algorithm end to end and also how it
gets customized to different kind of a
problem that you come across great
the the program culminates with the
certificate issued by IIT contour and
this certifies that you have completed
the core courses to their satisfaction
that they can put their name behind your
skills
um it gives you exposure along the way
to the newest types of things uh that I
mean she mentioned including generative
AI things like champ and uh chat GPT and
prompt engineering for it
um we talked extensively about the
integrated projects uh and how these
create artifacts for your portfolio
things that you can demonstrate as
practical experience
and then master classes so master
classes add a lot of value to the
program I mean I don't think when people
are able to hear from faculty members
about
Advanced topics like you talked about
that's correct actually so what happens
Master glasses will be delivered by some
professional coming from some Professor
who are who are having a lot of
experience in terms of working with
these projects these uh problems so they
come up with their own understanding of
what kind of challenges they have faced
how did they sought out or what are the
things you should focus upon when you
are actually working on a project so
that adds a lot of value different
people coming from different domain
telling students that what kind of uh
problem solving is happening in a
particular industry so that's pretty
helpful actually
yeah thank you
um speaking of the faculty IIT Contour
is it was established in 1959 it is an
educational institution with a long
history
um it is uh got a reputation throughout
India and the world
because it
hosts things like the national
blockchain project for India doing
Advanced Research into blockchain
technology and its applications in
different domains working with the
national and state governments
on different projects as well as
industry also the interdisciplinary
Center for cyber security and cyber
defense where uh this is the
place where
defenses of the infrastructure of
Indian
including the power grid banking system
that type of thing
um
these types of advanced cyber defenses
are are conceived there it's a a hub of
Technology
research and development it's the type
of thing that you would love to have on
your resume because people will
recognize the name of IIT contour and
we're extremely proud to be offering
this in other programs in conjunction
with them so
for this program you must be a
bachelor's degree holder so I know that
a number of you
responded that you're still in school
studying for your degree if you happen
to be scheduled to receive your degree
sometime before this program would end
so if you enroll in projecting out the
11 months of the program if you are
scheduled to receive your degree before
that ends then you can be eligible for
this program as well so
if you're earlier in your career you may
want to wait a bit but for those who
have a bachelor's degree you must have
some also that you have
we ask for two or more years of
experience although that is not a hard
and fast requirement
um but I mean can you comment on
what it is that helps people be
successful with regard to having that
background in programming mathematics
and what the value of the work
experience is a prior knowledge and and
our experience and programming will be
very helpful we'll catch up things a
little faster uh you will have
understanding of how a code is working
and you'll not find it uh like some
people might find it uncomfortable when
they're they have not done any
programming prior to this these sessions
but having said that I want to tell you
that that Python Programming is pretty
simple to grasp and even if you do not
have uh entire programming experience in
terms of you might have done Fair bit
here and there but then you have lost
the touch it doesn't actually create a
problem python is pretty simple language
to to work but understand this entire
program is Hands-On and every section
will have the coding experience so you
can understand from that that how
important it is to have some
understanding of the programming and the
other thing is that when you talk about
work experience actually work experience
helps both ways one is that you
understand
how how you can solve a particular
problem in your day-to-day business that
you are doing and also helps students
who probably do not have much experience
to understand that how different uh
Professionals in their field how they're
mapping these algorithms and thinking
how they can solve some problems in in
their their industry so that's how it
goes yeah and then one of the
interesting things about the work
experience is that because you're coming
into the program with generally with
other people who are working
professionals there's a lot of like
cross pollination a little cross
discussion about
what do you do in your job and how does
it work and this is what I do in my
industry and you can learn a lot from
each other in that respect because this
is a little a lot of live interaction in
the program both during the classes and
on the community
bulletin board where you can talk to
your peers
about that so that's a really
interesting and valuable networking
opportunity
so we talk about the modules I mentioned
modules before and this program is
designed to take you through
um
a set of
steps that will build your skills
to enable you to succeed in the next
step in the process and you comment a
bit about how this flow goes so as we
have mentioned earlier that mathematics
and and basic programming is important
to to start your journey into this
particular field so we have taken care
of that we give you a mathematics and
statistical essential plus a program
refresher so this makes sure that you
are aligned with the entire program in
terms of what basic mathematics is
required and how how you can start with
the programming so this is a pretty
important section I would say because it
builds the entire foundation for you so
here what happens is we'll talk about
some mathematical Concepts predominantly
about vector algebra and differential
calculus but in a very simple terms not
too complicated too much too much
complication we do not
incorporate over here we just give the
understanding of it how it works and how
it will be useful later on and then in
programming also we tell you how a
program works how python Works entirely
how to understand a particular code how
to understand different component of it
then once that is done we move to a
science with python so this part where
we focus upon different kind uh data uh
processes that you can you can you you
have to work upon so it would be like it
could be feature engineering or it could
be some basic data preparation that you
are doing or it could be data
transformation
sometimes we want to another so that the
machine learning algorithms can pick it
up so all that will be taught over here
so this is basically uh giving you all
the important aspects of data processing
data pre-processing that we talk about
or data preparation which is very very
important because once you have the
right data then only the algorithm will
work perfectly so here we'll be dealing
with some statistical technique some
simple aggregation transformation that
will be taught to you using python
then you move to machine learning where
we'll be dealing with the machine
learning algorithm we'll start with what
machine learning is what can different
types of learning which are there it
should be supervised unsupervised
semi-supervised and so on and then again
uh I want to tell you here that once we
deal with a particular concept we
introduce you to a case study and then
we we solve that case study using that
concept that we have learned so we'll be
doing a lot of coding also so we'll
teach you the entire machine learning
different albums so how do they work how
to implement what kind of challenges you
face or how to fine-tune a particular
model then once machine learning is done
we move to deep learning with Cura flow
where we deal with the Deep learning
Frameworks we start with a simple neural
network
how does it work how the how this this
concept of neural network has been can
from a biological neuron and then how to
implement it then there we also talk
about different types of neural networks
that you can build you have simple
neural networks or artificial neural
networks that we call it then we have
convolutional neural networks you have
you have a record neural networks you
talk about Auto encoders so all these
networks will be taught to you and again
it will be implemented in Python using
Keras and tensorflow then we move to you
know as Essentials of generative AI
prompt engineering and chart GPT charged
GPT has been a path breaking application
that that you must have experienced so
there we talk about in general what is
generative Ai and uh how it is different
from a traditional AI that we talk about
what are the applications of it then we
discuss about prompt engineering how
does it work and how chart GPT can be
utilized for different
task by effective prompt and efficient
prompt that we talk about we also talk
about how you can custom train chart GPT
how do how does that work and then
eventually we talk about a Capstone
project so this Capstone project is
designed to test your understanding on
the entire machine learning life cycle
starting from uh getting the data then
understanding the data data preparation
then data transformation feature
engineering model building model
evaluation this entire task will be
tested for you and we will this Capstone
is a very comprehensive project and
again you have different options for the
Capstone also from a different industry
so that's what is Capstone in addition
to that you also get electives which you
can choose which is reinforcement
learning we talk about what is
reinforcement learning how does it work
and again how do we implement it then
you have advanced deep learning and
computer vision where we talk about how
to work with the images so image
processing and then how deep learning
come into the picture to to work with
the images should be some example could
be image segmentation or it could be
object detection that we talk about
then you also have natural language
processing and speech recognition which
focuses on on NLP tasks and also working
with the speech data and how do they how
do we take that as an input and probably
we can do sentence synthesis or or
speech to text or text to speech and
then you have master classes as
mentioned earlier also there will be
academic and Industry master classes so
this is a very helpful part where you
get to interact with industry experts as
well as some academic uh
experts who come and they they share
their own knowledge so this is how this
entire program is
thank you very much for that and and
just a reminder that the electives are
included in the cost of the program so
that
they're a way for you to kind of
customize
what you learn out of the program and
what areas of interest to you that you
want to take from it so
um very powerful you can take as many as
you as you wish as you have time for
Beyond
they give you an added layer of value in
this program
so we talk about
the integrated labs and the projects and
and the kinds of things you use and not
necessarily go through what each of
these are and what they're for but the
the general principle here
the gene is that when you're taking
someone through a class and
the topic requires you to deploy
some of these tools
you're actually showing people and
letting them use them themselves on
their on the Virtual Lab environment
right that's quite like you might walk
in the uh with the Deep learning
framework so you need you need Keras for
that or probably You're Building machine
learning models SK learn is there or
probably eventually you are deploying a
model so we will introduce you towards
to what is flask
so Mr Friend level uh we have different
kind of requirement and that's where we
teach python libraries which will help
you in terms of finishing that
particular task or a job which is there
and at different places different kind
of libraries different kind of
Frameworks we cover the entire uh
end-to-end implementation great
the nice thing is that when you do these
projects and these are examples of the
kinds of projects you would do during
the program or during the Capstone
um they're based on real world
challenges they let you look at
different aspects and different industry
domains and they produce when you do the
projects and the labs you produce
artifacts in your portfolio things that
you can then show to say this is how
I've used this skill this is how I've
used this tool and this is how I've
solved this type of problem so
these are examples there are many many
more that you do during the the program
as you can see
doing understanding of uh how a retail
firm acquires new customers looking at
the production optimization of processes
and
production manufacturing facility
looking at
the understanding the under the
underlying principles of fintech that
let you look at how to make credit
decisions
um it's it's a fascinating field and it
shows you how much of what you deal with
as as individuals in the real world
is now driven by the ai ai
now for example get an instant micro
credit decision
at the point of sale something that
couldn't be done if human beings had to
look at your credit history
[Music]
but any items allow fintech firms to do
things like that so it's really this is
a way to understand how AI is
Transforming Our World right that's
correct actually so it's going to help
you a lot I I want to add one thing here
I've been interacting offload with a lot
of students so I want to tell you that
what you mentioned is that because
they've solved these problems they get a
lot of confidence in terms of how to
take up a particular problem and then do
entire uh end-to-end uh uh finishing of
the project so they get the
understanding that when they're gonna
solve you know in a particular job or a
particular problem how they're gonna
take it and how gonna they're gonna
install entirely so it gives a lot of
confidence to students that they can
solve problems from different industry
they understand at each level what what
kind of job is required what kind of
tasks are required what Frameworks they
can use and eventually what kind of make
sure that you're not running into
blockers but also
again you get to choose which project
you want to work on what domain it's in
the most interest you out of the
different choices
and this is where you end up with that
um
confidence that you just mentioned on
the team that you can take a real world
problem
and demonstrate that you have the skills
and the understanding to be able to
build the solution for it
uh
that's basically the purpose of the
project right
that's good that's correct so in uh in a
very gradual manner we prepare you for
for I would say Capstone which is very
very much near to a real problem that we
saw also gradually understand that what
you are doing and eventually the one
Capstone is done you get a lot of
understanding that that happens in a
real world problem yeah and
you see gradually you know because
in each of the modules of the program in
each of the phases of the program you're
learning these new skills and techniques
but you're learning them in a context
where you learn how to
um and put them into Solutions so that
you've essentially learned about the
building blocks that ultimately you'll
use in your Capstone project so it's not
something that's completely unfamiliar
that you're getting thrown into
something you've built up to
um simply learn as the delivery partner
for IIT Contour
provides this ecosystem we have a
program manager who interacts with the
iitk and make sure that we are
delivering a program to their standard
when you enroll you enroll with a number
of other people on the same date and
manage that as a cohort so we assign
someone who will
be your Shepherd for your group to take
you through the process and
ensure that you're staying on track and
handling me questions or doubts for you
on that level
um the instructors of course in each of
the courses in each of the modules are
going to help you succeed
that particular phase of the program
then you have the ability to draw on the
other people that you're learning with
your peers
um
through live interactions and but also
through the
Community other features in the program
and then the way we've designed the
platform the curriculum the resources
not only live classes but the self-study
video and reading materials and helping
us through the Virtual Lab environment
the sample data sets that you use in
your exercises all of this is designed
to maximize
your opportunities for success and I'm a
team is going to show us a little bit of
that
um
and how it actually works at this point
so
I'm going to stop sharing my screen on
my team and I'm going to let you go in
and show a little bit of the flavor of
this talking about like it talks about
all these are the sections that you will
be covering in this particular
production and then once you go to a
particular section like if I talk about
machine learning that I was saying that
you'll have to cover supervised and
supervised and all that so here you get
this
self-learning module and in this
self-learning
you have this
pre-recorded videos now this is just for
your your uh help purpose in a sense if
you just want to understand a bit on on
the topic and then come to the session
uh it's your wish so this is just for
your for for your uh reference purpose
it's not that you have to close
self-recorded videos and learn from that
only it's not that it's just a reference
for you kind of a study material uh if
you get time go through it and then you
can come back to the session and we can
go in detail about it so this is just
for your reference purpose so here you
get self learning videos then you your
lab is integrated in your LMS itself so
you don't have to actually install
anything on your system you don't have
to worry about getting the right uh uh
python version and write libraries you
just log into your system log
and then you can start working I'll get
to the lab little later let me just tell
you a few more things here the other
thing that is very useful over here is
that uh once we start working on on
certain algorithms we'll be working on a
case study and you need those uh data
sets to work with so here you get all
the data sets so if you see here you can
download the data sets and whatever a
presentation the trainer is using you
can download from here under ebook
section so all the material that you
need for the classes will be available
over here same material will be used by
the trainer and and everything you can
download and you can work with the
trainer you don't have to search for the
data or you don't have to wait for
trainers to share the data with you
that's pretty beneficial actually and
then once you finish the entire program
this particular section you'll have your
assessment here itself and if you see
here they're different
case studies given so you have Mercedes
bench Greener manufacturing which is
pretty interesting project you have
income qualification from a world Bank
you have a healthcare project you have a
book rental recommendation project so
you need to pick up one of them to solve
it and then you need to submit in order
to get your certificate done this also
will be here and the good thing is that
once you click on any of the problem if
I go to Mercedes or income qualification
it gives you the problem statement talks
about what are the tasks here also gives
you the link to download the data or
data dictionary that is required
so everything you got get over here
itself then when you go to the lab
so the lab looks like this you will have
your lab integrated as we mentioned once
you launch you can start
using the lab the code book that we are
talking about now typically this is how
the session goes I'll be starting this
session like suppose I'm talking about
feature in engineering that's the topic
for the day this notebook will be shared
with you in advance all the coding is
also installed it will show you so now
this
section covers all these topics this
particular notebook covers all these
topics are here which has been given to
you in a curated manner then we talk
about what's the agenda which explain to
you different concepts and once we
explain the concept you will see that we
have taken a problem over here and then
we're gonna solve it so we talk about
the problem here itself the code has
been given in advance we explain every
every line of the code how it works
what's the purpose of the code and what
is the result coming so we talk about
that and then we explain you the entire
concept so that's how it goes in the lab
the good thing is you don't have to
download anything you can start working
over here itself
and all this will be given to you in
advance now sometimes what happens you
might ask something extra over here with
what what we are doing you might ask how
to do this or that so I might add some
extra lines over here and once I add
anything at the end of this session I'll
share this entire notebook with you with
the updated codes how do I share we have
a community and that also you can access
from the lab itself so if you go back to
the lab here you have a community
section now the community section helps
you in terms of interacting with each
other and also to interact with trainers
so in case we are having sessions
suppose uh for five days in a week or
four days in a week you have some some
time off or during those off days you
are working on a particular problem you
got stuck you can put in the community
we will solve it for you you can
interact with the trainers and whenever
I have to share something extra I can
upload it over there so even trainers if
they want to share something they can
share with you that's where Community
come into the picture now if suppose uh
while working on the LMS or or you have
some other trouble happening you can
always go to our help section and 24x7
the help is available you can raise a
ticket you can tell about your problem
and one of us will get in touch with you
to solve your particular problem once
you finish everything once you submit
your report so I submit your project you
go to certificate and your certificate
will be unlocked that's how generally
the LMS work
thank you that's a great overview
um
I'm going to go ahead and move back to
our presentation but that
gives everybody a flavor of how
you interact with the system how you
fund your courses and how you actually
do The Learning Experience
really
valuable overview for us so thank you
for that
um
as I mentioned this program is
developed by IIT Contour it's under
their supervision and Professor kakar is
a
the
particular point of contact who
organizes and supervises the program
and he is
a very distinguished member of The
Faculty he's one of the people that
you'll hear from in the master classes
so we're extremely pleased to be working
with him and with the institution
hmm
some learner outcomes when you enter
into this program
you as I mentioned working fairly with
other working professionals that are
students with you and they may come from
companies like this this is a sampling
of people of the companies people have
come from and participated in our
programs they may come from I.T from the
consultancy world from uh banking to
financial but really it comes from a
across the board in all different
Industries at this point doesn't it I
mean
that's correct actually and they come
with different companies different
industry different vertical which kind
of actually helps a lot they start
interacting with them they get to know
what they are hoping from the program as
well as what kind of uh
application they want to develop further
and some of them actually bring their
problem also in the classroom to discuss
which actually adds extra advantage in a
sense that you get to know about some
some problems that they that people are
facing in real time
So based on what we've discussed with
you so far are you
interested in enrolling in the program
I'll start this poll we'll just keep yes
or no question so we'll just keep it
open for about 15 seconds
let us know
and I will close the program and Pull It
in three
yeah over 90 that you are interested so
share with you the details of how to get
that started
the enrollment steps are very
straightforwards at simplylearn.net I
will put that into
the chat
and either contact us through that email
address or through our program web page
back to the chat here
and what they would do once you've
contacted are learning Consultants they
will ask you some questions about your
background they'll verify that you have
the bachelor's degree requirement met
um they'll ask about your work history
um there will be a kind of a brief
assessment test on your background in
understanding of mathematics and
programming just to be capable of that
Marcus put his email into our chat Mark
we have your email because
participation in here so you can
in the final survey when you leave the
program you'll be able to also give us
your email and and
information
let's details the next program classes
start in August with an induction
session that orientation that I mean
mentioned uh on 27 July so that's next
week
and you start the program and take
advantage of the classes that start in
August
we say that there are limited seats
available this is because we can't
accommodate an unlimited number of
people in the cohort already limited to
about 25 or 30 people
per enrollment cohort so that our
instructors have enough time to devote
to individual Learners in each class
and the program cost is a one lock 53
400 rupee Emi financing is available at
5220 per month
so your uh
I have talked about this bonus offer
to to find out specifically what the
discounted off of these fees
or reward for
attending this webinar and enrolling in
the August take advantage of that
so knowing that the next cohort starts
in August
how soon are you interested if you are
one of the people who said you're
interested
how soon would you like to join the
program
and
straightforward question so I'll leave
this open for another 10 seconds
I'm going to close the poll in three
two
one
and
over a third of our audience would like
to get started in that August cohort so
that's great
um again
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
if you're looking uh
September October also contact us but I
recommend that anybody who's interested
in this program even if you're looking
to do it more than six months from now
do contact us we'll keep in touch with
you about future cohorts we'll be able
to answer any further questions we got a
question in the chat about
demo classes so if you ask our uh
learning Consultants that ask us at
simplylearn.net they can point you to
resources that will give you an examples
of what the
learning experience is like so
we recommend that everybody contact us
if you're interested in this program
move forward
this is where we talked
about questions and answers
and take this uh
big slide off the screen because you
probably prefer to talk to
I'm a teen rather than the slide so
um we've got a bunch of questions in the
Q a and I'm going to focus on that
um
can you tell karishik
how machine learning differs from Deep
learning or how deep learning is a
specific
um
topic area distinct from machine
learning sure so first of all you need
to understand that deep learning is a
subset of machine in terms of more
technical difference if I have to tell
you machine learning when we work with
we have to work on the data a lot we
have to extract we call it features so
extract some some understanding of the
data in a very Layman to tell you and
then feed that understanding to machine
learning then it learns deep learning is
a little more advanced think that way
and they can understand the deeper
meaning in the data on their own you
don't have to sit and and curate for
them that's how deep learning and
machine learning differ but having thank
you
so we have an interesting question from
the lava
if you first question is if you build an
AI what's the potential for doing a
startup company based on some AI
okay I would say in a very generic way
any any startup that you build it there
are two ways one is that you create
something new altogether so you move
from zero to one and another is that you
replicate something and if you ask me I
would always say that when you're
creating something new it has a lot of
potential and AI has that particular
potential where you can create something
new altogether so just work on the
problem that world is facing solve it
yeah I'm sorry I don't want to assume
um is that
if
AI goes to its logical conclusion do
people really need to learn so many
different programming languages if chat
GPT can write code for you so why is why
is it you want to to have the
the programming language skills
um and not rely solely on chat GPT
well probably we might reach that level
sometimes in in distance future I
wouldn't say it has happened right now
the the context of a code when you talk
about you need to still feed in that
information that what you are looking
and how you want to feel how you want
your final result to be done and then
you have to further customize it uh
chart GPT also it does not give you
entire ready-made solution although it
it helps you a lot so I'm saying
still go into that particular place
where you have to understand the whole
logic of the code and then probably you
can take help of some of the virtual
assistant but eventually you'll have to
understand the code in a better manner
yeah we live in a world already with you
know low Code and low code Solutions of
various types and so we still need
people who can assemble those pieces
into systems
it's necessary to understand some of the
technology behind that to do that
correctly
um
I do not have any experience or
knowledge in programming mathematics
what would you recommend for somebody
to gain that experience prepare for this
field if they're not already
in the position to start a program like
this
oh I would say keep it very simple start
with the basic mathematics some of the
maths that we talk about is the eighth
grade mathematics and and that's how it
starts so so it start uh simple keep it
very simple learn some basic mathematics
start with the programming if you and
programming is all about logical
intuition so if you have logical brain
programming will not be a problem at all
for you okay
uh have a question from uh it says Carr
who says I have five experience
five years of experience rather in IT
Tech Support engineering
uh two parts of the question is there a
job guarantee and is this a good career
field to move into the first part I'm
going to mention uh simply learn doesn't
provide a job guarantee but we do
provide certain Services that'll help
you with
job search and
preparation for your job so
um we do give that level of support
um but we don't this program offer a job
guarantee or placement
um the other part of this question you
comment on somebody with that it
background
it support background moving into Ai and
machine learning is that's going to be a
good career move
now it would be one thing I tell that
you have the entire domain expertise and
you also must be aware that what kind of
development is going to happen in your
own field so you know you start to
understand that if I'm talking about in
general tech support lot of applications
are there for for say uh NLP tasks okay
or it could be say predictive
maintenance if I'm talking about more on
a maintenance side it could be it could
be chat Bots for the basic support you
can create so I'm saying all these
things which are happening you need to
understand how it works then you will be
part of the team which will be
developing it
so so it's going to be a pretty good
feel for even for people who are into
tech support and you need to just find
the right uh path for that
it's somebody who caught a typo
somewhere in the presentation mentioning
cyber security although we did talk
about the cyber security Center at IIT
copper which is
one of it's more prestigious
accomplishments
um
how do you address somebody who has a
management background
has had some programming experience but
has been spending most of their time
over the last couple decades in
management is this a pivot they can make
um basically uh we do a lot of program
for the higher management also where
they want to understand how these topics
work and how it will help their business
whatever vertical they are working so
one part is that where I start talking
that okay AI will do this or that and
then the second part would be that I
need to understand how practical some of
the solutions would be if I have to
implement in my own uh probably in a
in my position if I'm implementing in my
own department so it helps
in terms of understanding that what all
things are there what are their
limitations how it will actually help
you in terms of with your team with your
department
depends on whether your focus is to
understand applications of AI as a
manager
um how you would deploy it within your
organization and make use of it uh
versus becoming a particular
practitioner in Building Systems so
um there are different programs you can
pursue for different those this one is
more of the latter in terms of
helping you understand the technology
use the technology build Solutions with
it um
you have a question about how this
differs from other simply learned
programs is uh I'm a teen mentioned we
are affiliated with various universities
in India and the United States so people
have different preferences about which
university that they would prefer to be
affiliated with
um many of the the issues or techniques
or skills are similar in the programs
but for example in this program you'll
be learning and taking master classes
with IIT Concord professors if you took
it from a different uh
university-affiliated program you would
obviously be hearing from their faculty
members so
um it's
that's the main qualitative difference
um
how will this course help in getting
jobs related to Ai and machine learning
so
um just the preference to the I'm A
team's answer is
in order to get a job in any field it is
valuable to have experience in that
field
um if the Catch-22 obviously is you
can't gain experience without getting a
job unless of course you have some way
of showing that you use these skills
you've solved these problems here are
examples so I'm a team would you like to
comment on how this course helps people
get job ready and find those jobs
so as we have been talking about that we
deal with the dealing with the concepts
right from the foundational level to the
advanced level and we prepare you in
terms of solving some real world problem
so so how does it help it it hones your
skills to probably develop your skills
in terms of whatever is required for AI
and ml jobs and it also gives you idea
or gives you a understanding that how a
machine learning Project Life Cycle goes
what kind of problem you'll be solving
what kind of skill set are required what
kind of programming skills is is a must
have all that will be covered in the
program and eventually this will prepare
you for your job rules
um what are the course timings what what
days are the classes typically in these
courses
uh generally these courses if I'm not
mistaken Stuart this is for weekend
batch on it right so this is yeah so
this goes for four hours on Saturday
four hours on Sunday so eight hours in a
in a week and then the platform is
available 24x7 for Learners to do the
preparation and homework and projects in
between so they can put in those hours
at any time that they they have
um
the tools that are given in the program
are is
so the question is is a page
subscription or free version with
limitations and correct Austin darling
pardon that's free of cost no yeah it's
the charge over there yeah what's
included in the in the course is that
simply learning paying the
subscription to the different companies
so that for our students it's not an
additional fee and you get access to the
paid generally the paid version for
example if you're using cloud services
uh you're using a full uh privileged
account that allows you to
configure multiple
virtual machines and that type of thing
so
um
are electives available or do we need to
choose a few but you can choose as many
or as few of the electives as you wish
they are included in the cost of the
program so it's really based on your
interest in the amount of time that you
have
um
are there Hands-On projects for prompt
engineering and deep learning
there are actually and prompt
engineering is focused upon effectively
utilizing prompts it could be let's say
develop a Storyline by giving
appropriate prompt and then interacting
with the chat GPT and similarly in deep
learning you have image classification
retinopathy which is there you have Loan
Data analysis you have a traffic signal
predictions all that is there
okay
um
we have a an interesting question from
an anonymous user who asks
could you
address how AI
can help in the field of psychology
psychological research
um
how could psychologists use
like a psychologist how they can use
although I'm not uh I don't have any
domain expertise on that but I can say
that if you have uh some kind of data
associated with the with whatever study
you are doing or could be patient data
that you have it could be mainly on
unstructured data and if you want to
understand it in a better manner find
some some deep patterns you can you can
use uh probably deep learning Frameworks
like uh like Ordnance and all to
understand the speech or text in a
better manner that's what you can do
and I would recommend that to the user
to to look on Google for a project that
would from the 1960s called Eliza
e-l-i-z-a
and Eliza was one of the first efforts
at natural language processing
and it was in the form of a virtual
psychologist so they were trying to show
that a computer system could mimic some
of the techniques of psychotherapy
asking questions and evaluating answers
um the history is fascinating the
technology was extremely primitive
as we can tell because psychologists
still have jobs and
don't use a lot of machine different
psychology but
um
it's it's a fascinating story I'll get
Eliza from the 1960s
um
will the syllabus also cover price
forecasting techniques using Ai and ML
and my understanding is that you will
learn techniques that you can then apply
in that domain all right
and that's correct uh you will be
learning all that
programs for management leaders I would
contact us they ask us at
simplylearn.net learning Consultants ask
about that you can also see on our
website some of that as well
um
what timing or typical on the weekend
classes are those in the evenings or in
the mornings
uh different batches actually there will
be some batches which run in the morning
some of them run in the evening
Consultants to give you a specific
program schedule on that
um
that's all the questions we have time
for I do have one other question here
I think is is
really important from Asha who says if
12 years of experience a good package
now but if I go into this new technology
will they consider my existing package
so if somebody's already in a well-paid
position looking to Pivot or or move
into the new skill area
what can they expect and what are the
ways that they can maximize
or minimize the impact on their
short-term income
on short-term income sorry I missed the
first part yeah the idea is that the
person with 12 years of experience
they're making a good salary package
currently they're worried that if they
shift into this new field that they'll
have to take a step back
what would you say I would say this way
you wouldn't have to take a step back
probably what you might think is that
you don't get appropriate
appreciation in your packages salary
packages to start with you might be
getting something similar what you are
making right now I would say take that
particular plunge because after that you
will see exponential growth that's what
is happening yeah if there's also
different ways of approaching the
problem where
um you might look at it as a way to
enhance your current career paths if
you're in a particular industry if you
have a particular domain knowledge
um and you then add this set of skills
to it you may be able to find ways to
build on your current position and
um yeah the the AI and ml rules to it so
with that I'm going to apologize to
everyone whose questions I did not get
to
um
quite a few but um
limitations of time I'm going to go
ahead and
move to the last part of our webinar
do you have questions contact us at ask
us at simplylearn.net
you may be able to help you with some of
those
and
there we go
brings up our final poll question for
the audience are you interested in
getting assistance from us would you
like us to reach out proactively to you
uh if you would like us to
give you a call
let us know here
I'll just leave this open for another
four three two one
about two-thirds of you are interested
it's great I'll show you the result
and so
for those of you who answered yes you
can expect a phone call we will be
contacting uh all the people who
indicated they're interested in this
program
and
want to put into the chat one last time
the information about our course page
and our email address
I want to take this opportunity to thank
I'm a team
so much for your
generosity with your time and your
knowledge today
um really appreciate that
thanks Stuart thank you so much
and I want to thank everyone here
who took time out of their evening or
their morning depending on where you are
to join us
to hear about this program
and about the opportunities the AI and
ml career field
and we certainly hope that we can
welcome you into the Learning Community
with IIT comcor and simply learn
so with that I want to scan the QR code
to get to our webpage or use the link in
our chat or if you want to
email us at ask us at simplywin.net we'd
love to hear from you
and as I said I hope we can welcome you
into our learning community
that concludes our webinar for today
thanks again
thank you